if you are regularly consuming alcohol
it is holding you back even if you're
only very periodically consuming it it's
holding you back there is no positive
physiological benefit that comes from
drinking the facts are absolutely there
it's 100% poison it's neurotoxic it's
terrible for our brains it's terrible
for our bodies and yet so prevalent in
society everybody is searching for
Optimal Health Peak Performance more
productivity in their work how to lose
way and yet they're not realizing that
this vision of what alcohol-free could
feel like that is the one thing that
will give them what they are looking for